Y
OUT OF THIS.
>> Sean: GREG PALKOT, PLEASE
STAY SAFE.
NOW THE THIRD DAY OF
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION
HEARINGS WERE A JUDGE KETANJI
BROWN JACKSON TOOK PLACE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
JUDGE JACKSON WAS ONCE AGAIN
PRESSED ON HER RECORD
SURROUNDING ALLEGATIONS OF BEING
VERY LENIENT AND LENIENT
SENTENCING FORD CHILD
FOR CHILD PORN OROFFENDERS.
>> THE GOVERNMENT ASKED FOR AND
HAPPENS RELATED TO PREVIOUS AND
TO CHILDREN, THE NATURE OF THESE
CHILDREN, AND YOU SAID YOU
AREN'T GOING TO APPLY IT BUT
WHAT YOU SAY IS YOU DON'T HAVE A
POLICY OBJECTION?
WHY DIDN'T YOU APPLY THE
ENHANCEMENTS THEY WERE ASKING
FOR?
>> SENATOR, I'VE ANSWERED THIS
QUESTION MANY TIMES FOR MANY
SENATORS WHO HAVE ASKED ME.
I'LL STAND AND WHAT I'VE ALREADY
SAID.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE NOTHING TO
ADD ABOUT WHY THESE CRIMES, WHY
THESE IMAGES IN YOUR VIEW DO NOT
SIGNAL AN ESPECIALLY HEINOUS OR
EGREGIOUS CHILD PORNOGRAPHY
OFFENSE?
>> Sean: INTERESTING PART IN
YOUR EXCHANGE, YOU ASK
JUDGE JACKSON WHY SHE IN ONE
CASE APOLOGIZED TO A CONVICTED
PEDOPHILE AT SENTENCING.
WHY WOULD YOU APOLOGIZE YOU ARE
GIVING THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE TO
OR WHAT THE PROSECUTORS WANTED?
>> SHE GAVE THAT A CONVICTED
CRIMINAL THREE MONTHS.
HE WAS ELIGIBLE FOR UP TO TEN
YEARS IN PRISON.
GAVE THEM THREE MONTHS AND
APOLOGIZED TO THEM.
THEY HAD OVER 20 HOURS OF
QUESTIONING, I THINK HER RECORD
IS PRETTY CLEAR WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIME AND CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO APOLOGIZES
TO THE CRIMINALS.
ONE LENIENT SENTENCE AFTER
ANOTHER, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO CRIMES BY THIS IS
SOMEBODY I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT.
>> Sean: PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
HAVE TIME ALL DAY TO WATCH A
HEARINGS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE WHICH YOU BROUGHT TO THE
NATION'S ATTENTION FIRST, THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF FACTORS IN PLAY
HERE AND ONE IS A RECOMMENDATION
OF THE PROSECUTORS THAT GOT
CONVICTIONS IN THESE CASES.
SHE WOULDN'T LISTEN TO THE
PROSECUTORS' RECOMMENDATION NOR
WOULD SHE GO ALONG WITH FEDERAL
GUIDELINES FOR SENTENCING.
AND SHE WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
LENIENT IN ALMOST EVERY CASE.
I DIDN'T SEE A CASE WHERE SHE
WASN'T.
>> 100% OF THE TIME.
MULTIPLE CHILD PORN CRIME
OFFENSES AND IN EVERY CASE THAT
SHE'S HAD CHILD PORN CASES, SHE
SITS BELOW WHAT THE PROSECUTOR
WANTED, BELOW THE NATIONAL
GUIDELINE 100% OF THE TIME AND
SHE CAN'T EXPLAIN IT.
WE TRIED TO ASK HER DAY AFTER
DAY, HOUR AFTER HOUR, SHE HAS NO
EXPLANATION FOR IT.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WATCHING THIS WANT TO SAY,
LISTEN, I WANT SOME AND
PROTECTING CHILDREN WHO'S GOING
TO BE TOUGH ON CHILD CRIMINALS
AND NOT APOLOGIZE TO THEM.
WHY SHOULD SHE
>> Sean: SHE GAVE ASPEECH AT MIL
INTERNET SPEECH SHE SEEMED TO SE
6019 PROJECT AND CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, BUT LISTENING TO HER
ANSWERS TO YOU AND OTHERS ON THE
COMMITTEE YOU WOULD THINK THAT
SHE NEVER SAID THOSE THINGS TO
THOSE STUDENTS IN THE LAW SCHOO.
>> SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY DESPITE THE FACT SHE HAS
PRAISED AND SAID SHE WHAT
THEY AREN'T ONES I AGREE WITH
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT I CAN'T
VOTE FOR SOMEBODY ON THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT WHO IS GOING TO
APOLOGIZE TO CRIMINALS, WHO IS
NOT GOING TO BE TOUGH WHEN YOU
NEED TO BE TOUGH IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CHILDREN.
AND I JUST...
YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO WHEN
THE CLIMB DOWN MY TIME COME TO
SAY LISTEN, IF YOU ARE A CHILD
PREDATOR YOU ARE GOING TO JAIL
FOR A LONG TIME AND THAT'S
SOMETHING SHE HAS NOT BEEN
WILLING TO DO.
>> Sean: HOW DID SHE SAY THAT
EVERY JUDGE HAS A HIDDEN AGENDA?
THAT STRIKES ME IS CRITICALLY
ODD.
I THINK WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
JUDICIARY THAT BELIEVES IN
SEPARATE POWERS AND WOULD UPHOLD
THE LAW OF THE LAND BASED ON OUR
CONSTITUTION.
NOT GO BY, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER
THE HIDDEN AGENDA IS.
HAVE YOU FIGURED OUT HER HIDDEN
AGENDA?
>> I THINK HER AGENDA IS BASED
ON OUR BELIEVES AND HER BULLIES
ARE PRETTY CLEAR.
SHE THINKS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS TOO HARD ON CRIMINALS
AND THOSE WHO COMMIT CHILD SEX
OFFENSES, CHILD PORN OFFENDERS,
SHE THINKS THE SYSTEM IS TOO
HARD ON THEM FOR THAT'S WHY 100%
OF THE TIME THE SENTENCES HAVE
BEEN LESS THAN THE PROSECUTION
WANTED IN THE GUIDELINES.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
EVERY SENATOR IS GOING TO HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION.
TO VOTE ON THIS AND PUT THEIR
DIME DOWN AND I FOR ONE ARE
GOING TO VOTE NO.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE PROPER
VOTE FOR ANY REPUBLICAN.
I'M SURE MITT ROMNEY WILL VOTE
YES AND APPARENTLY E